imagine que você está em uma consulta
médica esperando ser atendido e na sala
de espera tem uma mesa de centro na sua
frente com algumas revistas algumas
revistas em particular chama a atenção
pelo conteúdo das manchetes e você olha
você sempre foi muito cético na verdade
você nunca acreditou muito em forma
mágica mas você teve uma curiosidade
naquele momento vamos dizer curiosidade
jornalística então você pega revista
começa a folhear vai naquelas matérias
onde você tinha notado a manchete e você
começa a perceber na matéria ele
descrevendo uma rotina é uma
possibilidade que pra você pode ser
realidade
então você já se arruma na cadeira seu
coração começa a bater um pouquinho mais
forte
você começa a se sentir bem você se
imagina com a barriga seca com o corpo
sarado usando uma sunga na praia usando
um biquíni na praia e vocês naquele
momento você decide então vou mudar
minha vida e agora você pega seu celular
você tira uma foto daquela matéria onde
explica o passo a passo para chegar
nesses objetivos que estão aqui
destacados e você sai dali da consulta
médica você passa numa loja de
suplementos alimentares e você compra
não mais 4 se fala no decidiu comprar um
tem que investir e no caminho então você
passa também em uma academia do seu
bairro você fala eu quero um plano mais
completo não por um por seis meses
eu estou decidido que vou fazer isso no
outro dia você acorda com aquela energia
toda você vai se alimenta bem de manhã
você separa os seus alimentos para comer
de três em três horas você vai pro
almoço com uma comida leve à tarde
também à noite você vai na academia você
vai dormir cansado mas realizado
você tá bem no segundo dia tudo se
repete esse ritual saudável se repete
é incrível ter a sensação no terceiro
dia porém um amigo te liga e você e seu
amigo tinha um ritual juntos e ele fala
vamos almoçar juntos e vocês um ritual
que era comer uma hamburgueria na cidade
que ela é famosa por ter ingredientes
extremamente exagerados e você fala bom
já que me alimentei dois dias bem né
eu posso ir e você vai conhecer amigo
meio sem culpa
você vai lá como seu hambúrguer volta
pela mantendo aí sim a rotina de
exercícios do dia e você vai para o
quarto dia no quarto dia porém novamente
o pessoal da sua faculdade do seu
trabalho te chama para fazer um rap hour
e você fala e de fato um detalhe o
retorno no mesmo horário da academia
você pensa bom eu vi no youtube que o
marcio atalla falou que se eu fizer três
dias de exercício na semana me lembro de
um monte de doenças
eu já fiz então você vai tranquilo por
seu rap hour
você chega lá no próximo dia você bebeu
um pouco nesse rap ao você já está numa
numa ressaquinha no próximo dias e já se
alimenta mal novamente e você começa a
viver esses boicotes dia após dias até
que duas semanas depois você volta se
exatamente aquela mesma pessoa que você
era antes da consulta médica
eu sinceramente espero que isso não
tenha acontecido só comigo
tomara que todos vocês tenham feito isso
não me senti bem mão e por que isso
acontece a gente o primeiro motivo é
porque a decisão que você toma de mudar
a sua vida ela não é uma decisão
unilateral ela não é uma coisa que você
faz uma vez só
a decisão acontece em todos os momentos
a todos em todos os lugares
você decide quando você vai atravessar a
rua você decide quando você é alguém que
fecha no trânsito você vai atrás da
pessoa com raiva prazo pra xingar ela
seja a fazer o que você decidiu que vai
comer o que vai usar o que vai fazer com
quem você vai sair você está tempo todo
decidindo e quem é o responsável por
boicotar esse cara aqui ó elite boi
conta por causa dessas decisões
constantes e você deve pensar bom eu sei
o que eu decido na verdade você não sabe
e quem explica isso é o povo é crime
onde na sua teoria do cérebro tripartido
ele fala que nosso cérebro dividido em
três partes net partido e ele disse que
a primeira parte o cérebro reptiliano e
esse cérebro basicamente é responsável
por sobreviver
então é essa composição responsável por
estar atenta o que está ao seu redor e
evitar riscos então é quando você toma
um susto você reais seu coração bate
mais rápido você começa a sua talvez
você reage ao mundo que está lá fora
isso tudo de forma inconsciente
a segunda parte do cérebro é o cérebro
olímpico
é ele que lei entende gera sentimentos
dentro de você
ele que faz você ficar triste feliz com
amor com raiva com ódio com aquela fala
se nós hoje eu tô numa ansiedade o mal
você não sabe que esse sentimento dentro
de você e essa é a parte do cérebro que
produz essa memória afetiva em você
a terceira parte do cérebro a nossa
parte mais evoluída é o que nos difere
dos demais seres vivos é o neocórtex que
é formado pelos dois hemisférios do
córtex pré-frontal esse carinho aqui o
responsável por fazer com que você
raciocine por exemplo se eu falar para
perguntar pra vocês onde você algum dia
vocês nem eram nascidos
talvez onde vocês estavam no 11 de
setembro
sinceramente eu lembro exatamente da
cena que eu tava estudava na escola
ainda eu lembro do cheiro do do momento
lembro quem estava comigo eu lembro de o
ver na tv o que estava acontecendo
lembra exatamente e essa parte do
cérebro é responsável por conseguir
criar alguma coisa do abstrato então
essa parte do cérebro responsável por
fazer com que você imagine que você
entender os porquês por trás de tudo e
você vai para e pensa
bom se eu tenho um cérebro uma parte do
cérebro super inteligente eu tome as
decisões a partir dele não só desses 85
por cento das decisões de acordo com o
pesquisador são tomadas pelos dois
cérebros mais primitivos você é movido
por sentimento e emoção você só não sabe
que você acha que você raciocina e
racionalizar tudo e não é verdade por
exemplo no caso da academia você decidiu
baseado num sentimento que você mesmo
gerou dentro de você você decidiu que
você se inscrever numa academia que você
compra o cliente quiser fazer sua vida
mudar mas você nem sabia se você tivesse
racionalizado muito provavelmente você
teria ido numa nutricionista
muito provavelmente você ter estudado a
possibilidade de ter escolhido aquilo
que era melhor pra você
pois bem toda essa teoria que eu tô
falando pra vocês eu não sabia de nada
dela em 2007 eu era estudante de
engenharia elétrica que noroeste estava
aqui no pt e dois anos antes da minha
entrada no quando eu passei no
vestibular eu vivi um momento
absurdamente feliz eu acho que vocês
todos aqui passaram pelo vestibular por
uma provação e é o momento de uma extras
e absurda é um negócio muito feliz mais
ainda no meu caso porque meu pai era
engenheiro estava seguindo os passos
dele aquilo incrível dentro de mim
então à medida que o que eu entrei no
curso começou
a viver o curso eu fui me sentindo um
peixe fora d'água você deve pensar você
deve estar pensando se sentir desse
jeito porque você ia mal não mas não era
um dos momentos que eu ia bem também não
gostava só que me culpava tanto de não
gostar que eu ficava falando falar você
é o cara que precisa fazer aquilo você
tem que gostar desse negócio e einstein
tem uma frase que atribuir a ele que
fala se você julgar um peixe pela sua
capacidade de subir numa árvore ele vai
passar a vida inteira se sentindo um
imbecil e era assim que eu me sentia
pelos dois lados me julgava eu me senti
o brasil também porque não conseguia
fazer aquilo
então depois de passar por vários
momentos ruins eu tinha sim alguns
sintomas ruim dentro de mim eu tinha uma
rotina de seis horas que me sentia
pesado todo dia só seis horas
então um dia em maio de 2007 depois de
uma prova eu saí dessa prova eu tinha
ido médio
eu saí de lá e fui caro vamos dar um
chega já tinha dado algumas coisas
algumas biografias de pessoas que são
interessantes que eu vou mudar vou fazer
uma coisa diferente e optei pelo curso
que na época formava 150 mil pessoas por
ano
era uma norma número de agentes formados
ou seja o nome enorme número de
concorrentes à medida que o quando
migrado a si só complicada precisa então
fazer uma coisa diferente eu não posso
fazer igual na engenharia que eu vou
esperar cinco anos para ser feliz quando
me informou que eu fiz
sabendo que a vida é uma série de
decisões eu comecei a pôr algumas metas
porque eu sabia que eu tinha que cumprir
essas metas primeiro para saber que
estava indo na direção certa
eu não podia me dar ao luxo de viver
cinco anos depois só não gostei de novo
daí a besteira é uma vez é o que mais
erradas é burrice
então coloquei algumas séries de uma
série de metas onde eu definir algumas é
é alguns resultados de trabalho de
pesquisa acadêmica de relacionamento com
professores e de estudos de empresas que
eu queria participar o que ia trabalhar
eventualmente também colocou uma meta de
que eu tinha que morar fora do brasil
porque fora do brasil eu ia ter uma
experiência que quando eu voltasse pra
cá e diferenciada essas pessoas que
estão concorrendo comigo de certa forma
então vende o único carro que eu tinha a
única coisa que eu tinha na verdade e
fui morar lá na austrália
voltei de lá e tenho uma grande empresa
entre uma multinacional e tudo mais e eu
contando de forma rápida assim parece
que foi bem fácil mas não foi
sabe o que quer e que era muito
interessante no momento em que eu tinha
uma rotina de seis horas na engenharia
eu me sentia pesado no final do meu dia
me sentia mal meus sentimentos tomava
conta de mim e eu tinha medo de mudar
mas nesse momento quando eu estava na
administração que eu sabia que eu não
podia errar é querer demais não errar
mas eu que tinha que errar menos que eu
fiz eu tinha uma rotina de mais ou menos
16 ou 17 horas ou seja quase triplique a
minha carga de de vida vamos chamar
assim
mas a diferença é que nesse caso eu me
sentia muito melhor me sentia muito bem
aquele negócio de fazer bem e eu não
entendia porque eu entendia teoria não
entendia nada não conhecia e eu só sabia
que eu sentia aquele negócio ea vida foi
passando eu entrei numa empresa grande
que eu quero a minha missão e eu tinha
uma segunda meta eu sempre gostei de
deraa pessoas do tema liderança e eu
como não tinha uma equipe colocar uma
meta pra mim foi olha você eu quero que
você se torne flávio quero que você se
torne um gerente executivo de uma grande
empresa com 30 anos e eu não consegui
fazer o meu anúncio de de gerente de uma
grande empresa saiu com 30 anos e um dia
exatamente 30 anos e um dia nesse meio
do caminho eu aprendi uma forma que me
explicou exatamente o que eu tinha
vivido só não sabia como colocar isso
num frame vai numa tela em um formato e
essa teoria
ela é chamada de envolvimento total quem
escreveu foi o tony short selling e eles
eram ele era um dos dois pesquisadores
que trabalhavam com um pesquisa
esportiva de atletas de alto rendimento
e esses caras eles definiram um conceito
que faz com que você administrar seu
tempo mas a sua energia ea sua energia
segundo eles é formado por quatro
grandes forças
a primeira força física o quanto vocês
aqui estão cuidando do corpo de vocês
o quanto vocês tomam água quando você
dorme enquanto você o quanto você se
dedicam a esse corpo bom é a única forma
que vocês têm de contato com o mundo
externo
por que vocês não cuidam do corpo de
vocês a segunda força força emocional o
quanto você se relaciona com tanta
risada você dá no seu dia quantos bons
amigos você tem o quanto você cultiva
essa amizade quando você é feliz e
quando você deixa com que pensamentos
ruins assim como eu deixei tomem conta
da sua vida suas decisões
a terceira força é a força mental é
quanto o quão claro pra você está seu
próximo passo quanto você
definiu sabe o que fazer e onde chegar o
quanto você permite por exemplo se
desligar quando você sai da faculdade
num dia de 8 9 e 10 horas você chega lá
e você divide o que é trabalho que
esforço que a faculdade o que a casa e
que quer descanso o quanto você consegue
fazer isso e se você não tem essa
clareza dessas coisas eu sugiro a vocês
a leitura eo conhecimento porque é uma
coisa que faz toda a diferença
mas faltava uma coisa na minha teoria no
que eu vi que era a força espiritual é a
conexão que você tem alguma coisa maior
aonde você quer chegar o que você sonha
em fazer o quanto está claro para vocês
eu não sabia que lá atrás eu tinha um
propósito quando eu entrei na
administração eu sabia que tinha que
fazer e aquilo me movi movimentava que
fazer com que eu fosse a pessoa que eu
queria se não o que a pessoa que os
outros queriam que eu fosse
por mais que os outros sempre foram
foram bem intencionadas
gente eu deixo aqui meu relato eu deixo
aqui esse exemplo porque pra mim toda
essa história que estou contando pra
vocês fez toda a diferença de uma vida
inteira e por isso eu deixo também à
pergunta qual é o seu propósito
muito obrigado